[Música]
o inicia el juicio contra el ex
presidente francés nicolas sarkozy
acusado de intentar sobornar a un juez y
de tráfico de influencias a cambio de
información confidencial sobre
investigaciones por financiación ilegal
para su campaña presidencial de 2007
tenemos reporte desde parís
en eeuu es inminente la certificación de
los resultados de michigan y pensilvania
que en las elecciones del 3 de noviembre
le dieron la victoria a joe biden
mientras que los esfuerzos de donald
trump por impugnar la elección siguen
perdiendo peso
el demócrata electo avanza en su
formación de gabinete
y en brasil continúan las protestas
contra el racismo por tercer día miles
de ciudadanos llenaron calles de varias
ciudades en rechazo a la muerte de un
hombre afroamericano de seguridad de un
supermercado
aquí comienza la mañana y también las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez comenzamos el informativo
en francia el ex presidente nicolas
sarkozy será juzgado en parís por cargos
de corrupción y tráfico de influencias
quien lideró la nación del 2007 al 2012
es acusado de ofrecer favores a un juez
a cambio de información de una
investigación sobre financiación ilegal
de su campaña
sarkozy ha negado sistemáticamente
cualquier tipo de irregularidad
matías arraes informa
el ex presidente francés nicolas sarkozy
se presentará este lunes delante de los
jueces del tribunal de parís sarkozy
presidente de francia de 2007 a 2012
junto con su abogado elías goya serán
juzgados por corrupción y tráfico de
influencias en síntesis es acusado de
tratar de obtener información
clasificada de un juez conocido como el
caso de las escuchas los sucesos se
produjeron durante una investigación
para examinar si el difunto líder libio
muamar gadafi había financiado la
exitosa campaña de sarkozy para la
presidencia en 2007
no hay un documento no hay una foto ni
una cuenta ni una prueba material solo
está el odio el barro la mediocridad la
malicia y la calumnia es más beyoncé el
ácaro que mientras los investigadores
analizaban una serie de grabaciones
telefónicas sobre el caso de lydia
comenzaron a sospechar que sarkozy había
ofrecido a un juez un ascenso a cambio
de información sobre otra investigación
en la que se alegaba que sarkozy había
aceptado pagos
de la heredera de l'oréal liliane
bettencourt para la misma campaña
política
en su defensa los abogados de sarkozy
han argumentado anteriormente que los
magistrados que investigaban la presunta
financiación libia se excedieron en sus
facultades alegando una pesca del río
revuelto al intervenir sus
conversaciones entre septiembre de 2013
y marzo de 2014 violando el privilegio
abogado cliente aunque sarkozy ha sido
absuelto de las acusaciones de
betancourt tanto él como su abogado aún
se enfrentan a un máximo de 10 años de
prisión y una serie de multas
vamos a la capital francesa con nuestra
periodista en natalia ruiz buen día para
usted natalia y existe la posibilidad de
que se aplace la audiencia de hoy que se
sabe de eso
sí muy buenos días para todos ustedes
pues aquí ya en varias muchas personas
haciendo fila para poder entrar a la
sala de la corte corrección a la sala 32
es allí donde debe comenzar este proceso
del día de hoy un proceso que debe
comenzar dentro de una hora y media y
que normalmente va a ver a la sesión
pero al parecer podría aplazarse de al
menos una semana esto porque es idea así
verdad que es el magistrado que al
parecer del que se que nicolas sarkozy
habría querido pues corromper pues tiene
algunos problemas de salud así que
podría aplazarse esto a partir por una
semana este proceso que debe comenzar
hoy 23 de noviembre y debería ir hasta
el 10 de diciembre aproximadamente
natale a todo este caso de inicio con
escuchas telefónicas que pusieron en
duda los dineros de la campaña de la
presidencia de sarkozy cuál es la
supuesta procedencia de los fondos y que
otros casos en frente del ex presidente
bueno pues en realidad dos y dos varias
investigaciones en cuanto a esta
procedencia de los fondos por una parte
como lo decían en esta pieza que ustedes
escucharon hace un momento sobre el yang
betancourt la heredera de l'oréal la
mujer que la que era más la mujer más
rica de francia que habría pues he dado
unos unos dineros también a esa a esa
campaña del 2007 y los otros vendrían de
moamar gadafi y sería un hombre que se
llama el día de alta que jim y que es un
hombre de negocios franco-libanés quien
habría entregado unas dos son maletas
repletas de dinero al club de guión
quien era en esa época pues el
secretario general del elíseo por ahora
pues estos son al menos tres procesos en
contra de nicolás sarkozy que continúan
pues avanzando uno de ellos en marzo de
2021 que ya deberá abrirse veces a usted
natalia y cambiamos de tema en eeuu
inició el proceso de certificación de
los votos
el viernes georgia fue el primer estado
disputado en validar sus resultados a
favor de joe biden hoy se espera que
otros dos territorios pendulares se
michi
y pensilvania entreguen sus cuentas
finales y todo indica que también le
confirmarán la victoria al demócrata el
proceso es a menudo entendido como una
formalidad pero este año con donald
trump desafiando la legalidad de los
comicios la palabra final de los
delegados está en el foco de todos
veamos emitir un voto es sólo el
comienzo de lo que es un largo y sinuoso
camino desde el 3 de noviembre hasta la
investidura del 20 de enero porque en
eeuu elegir un presidente es un proceso
nacional y federal pero las reglas son
diferentes
estado por estado cómo funciona el
proceso primero están las cuentas
provisionales es decir cuando en los
estados se les dio el triunfo a dubai de
donald trump por ejemplo luego se
comprueban los números finales de los
condados con precisión es entonces
cuando los firman los funcionarios
estatales o los representantes
electorales los gobernadores también
pueden dar su sello de aprobación
entonces los delegados del colegio
electoral del estado pueden reunirse y
votar yo ya certificó sus resultados el
viernes
los condados de pensilvania tienen hasta
este lunes se espera que michigan
certifique también hoy luego el martes
se espera que nevada minnesota y
carolina del norte den sus sellos de
aprobación seguidos por arizona y
wisconsin hay varios plazos pero hay un
límite los 50 estados saben que el 8 de
diciembre es una fecha clave para todos
denominada el plazo de puerto seguro
deben entregar los conteos certificados
por tarde ese día si no quieren que el
congreso se involucre antes de la
reunión del colegio electoral el 14 de
diciembre con sus demandas sus
invitaciones a los legisladores de
michigan a washington y su exigencia de
un recuento en gioia donald trump es
visto por muchos como intentando de
descarrilar o retrasar lo que suele ser
una formalidad con la idea de que si los
resultados no se certifican entonces las
legislaturas estatales en las que los
republicanos son mayoría podrían elegir
partidarios de trump al colegio
electoral una anulación del voto popular
que es poco probable
que sería impugnada en los tribunales y
no cambiaría el liderazgo de joe biden
en ese organismo en américa latina las
protestas contra el racismo en brasil se
extendieron por tercer día consecutivo
en varias ciudades del país bajo el lema
de las vidas negras importan cientos de
personas se manifestaron contra la
muerte de un hombre a afroamericanos en
un supermercado de cadena ambos sujetos
fueron detenidos las autoridades sin
embargo dicen que la situación no
constituiría un acto de racismo
andrés meza muñoz tiene los detalles
[Aplausos]
el movimiento las vidas negras importan
reviven brasil
por tercer día consecutivo cientos de
personas se manifestaron en distintas
ciudades del país para reclamar justicia
por el caso de joao alberto silveira un
hombre negro que murió luego de que
fuera golpeado por dos guardias de
seguridad en un supermercado de cadena
en la ciudad de porto alegre
una situación que evoca la muerte del
estadounidense georges lloyd que desató
una ola de protestas alrededor del mundo
estamos luchando no sólo por joao
alberto que se fue sino por todas las
otras vidas que se perdieron y que
necesitan justicia hay que hacer
justicia
joao alberto habría tenido una discusión
con una cajera del establecimiento
comercial y por ello fue retirado por
los guardias de seguridad hasta la
puerta donde fue agredido ambos sujetos
fueron detenidos y responderán ante la
justicia por homicidio pero las
autoridades dijeron que no se trataba de
un acto de racismo cuando vas al mercado
te pueden asesinar cuando estás dentro
de tu casa también te pueden asesinar
por ser negro en brasil- cuando el
vicepresidente de la república dice que
no
en este país él no conoce brasil obras
el domingo los medios de comunicación de
brasil publicaron algunos detalles de la
vida de joao alberto entre ellos que
estuvo detenido por porte ilegal de
armas y violencia doméstica la
información fue aprovechada por grupos
de extrema derecha que en redes sociales
intentaron minimizar las acciones de los
dos guardias de seguridad este sábado el
presidente ya er bolsonaro restó
importancia al racismo estructural en su
país donde más de la mitad de la
población se identifica como negra o
mestiza
el paso de las tormentas yo estás dieta
por centroamérica y el caribe dejó al
menos 240 muertos miles de damnificados
y daños severos o muchos irreparables el
turismo pilar de la economía de la isla
colombiana de san andrés y de
providencia fue golpeado primero por la
pandemia de kobe 19 y luego por el
fenómeno meteorológico además en
honduras aquellos que perdieron sus
hogares luchan por tener un lugar donde
dormir informe de andrés amaya
ruina y destrucción la vida de los
residentes de san andrés y providencia
cambió cuando los huracanes y otras
jetta arrasaron con todo a su paso las
opciones para quienes se quedan no son
muchas
pasar la noche bajo carpas distribuidas
por el gobierno
hospedarse con algún vecino que no haya
perdido su casa o permanecer a la
intemperie
en una parte mañana vernos otra pero
estoy tratando de armar una carpa que
a rescatarme pero yo no me quiero ir yo
no me podía mover mi esposo me jalaba y
yo no podía quede totalmente hincho no
sabía qué hacer cuando mire que el
viento levantó en la brisa en la ráfaga
de las risas levantó la casa completa y
empezó a volar hasta tanque de gas voló
hasta el otro lado otro de los grandes
afectados fue honduras el gobierno ha
dispuesto refugios para los damnificados
pero el espacio se hace pequeño para
todos aquellos que quedaron sin hogar
muchos han tenido que dormir bajo los
puentes o en campamentos informales que
están llenos de gente que no está
comiendo aquí tan siquiera evidente el
mismo pueblo que debe dejar comida que a
la gente el presidente hondureño anunció
el inicio de una operación de limpieza
de miles de toneladas de lodo y
escombros
yota y eta dejaron igualmente miles de
damnificados en nicaragua cerca de 160
mil personas llegaron a estas refugiadas
en 250 centros de albergue pero poco a
poco han regresado a sus barrios en la
medida de lo posible la cruz roja estima
que cerca de 42 millones de personas
afectadas por el paso de yota y dieta en
honduras nicaragua guatemala y el
salvador
varios países avanzan en el
endurecimiento de medidas por kobe 19 en
canadá a la ciudad de toronto empieza
hoy a mediodía una estricta cuarentena
que incluye restricciones para salir de
casa solo para actividades esenciales en
alemania la canciller angela merkel
advirtió que habrá medidas más duras que
podrían anunciarse el 25 de noviembre en
reinounido del primer ministro boris
johnson detalla hoy el regreso de
restricciones selectivas que
sustituirían el actual confinamiento que
expira el 2 de diciembre se prevé que
anuncia cierta relajación para navidad
en francia en medio del segundo
confinamiento crecen las protestas en
especiales de dueños de comercios bares
y restaurantes
el presidente macrón hará anuncios
mañana irán introdujo restricciones más
estrictas desde el sábado para detener
una tercera ola de infecciones cerraron
los negocios no esenciales y se
impusieron restricciones de viaje en
corea del sur este martes entran en
vigor a reglas más estrictas de
distanciamiento social para mitigar una
tercera ola de infecciones cerraran
bares y discotecas y se limitarán las
reuniones religiosas y la asistencia a
restaurantes y cafés
entretanto en un desarrollo positivo se
anunció que la vacuna de la universidad
de oxford y la farmacéutica astrazéneca
proviene que previene la cob y 19 en un
74 por ciento de los casos en promedio
con una eficacia de entre el 62 y el 90
por ciento dependiendo de la dosis los
investigadores han señalado que es
eficaz al prevenir que muchas personas
se enfermen y que ha demostrado que
funciona bien en diferentes grupos de
edad
en hong kong el activista prodemocracia
joshua wong fue puesto en prisión
preventiva después de declararse
culpable de los cargos de organizar e
incitar protestas no autorizadas durante
las protestas antigubernamentales del
año pasado
world que tenía sólo 17 años cuando se
convirtió en el rostro de las
manifestaciones estudiantiles de en 2014
enfrenta una pena máxima de tres años de
cárcel por movilizarse cerca de la sede
de la policía sin permiso la sentencia
se entregará el próximo 2 de diciembre
estoy preparado para la delgada
oportunidad de salir libre este caso
llamará la atención del mundo hacia el
arbitrario poder del sistema judicial
criminal cuya imparcialidad está siendo
manipulada por la represión de beijing y
la violencia sistemática en mayor
detalle
hasta aquí el informativo pero ya
regresamos con más noticias sigan
france24
[Música]